going back to your like your weave phase
one thing i am kind of jealous of now
now that like living in japan
is that you you have like no fear when
it comes to
attempting japanese or like trying
japanese and everything like that be
like oh
chin chin you hear me
not that but like you you have like no
fear when it comes to like attempting
your japanese and
there are there have been times when
like in before we moved to japan because
i remember you were telling me the story
about
when i had my signing at bookwalker ax
and you actually met
one of the uh authors there uh i
i don't think that was the don macchiato
though i think i was
was it the one uh it was like the
second time i met you as was my older
brother
it might have been monsters might have
been muslim recently yeah it might have
been autism
i didn't honestly i think i know you
introduced i was like a bit drunk
because we're day drinking do you want
to explain the story
um so i was at an anime con with my
uh onishan my brother at um you could
have just said bro
i'm out
and um like all of us like we went with
the group like
we've gotten our friends some of our
friends from england and my brother
wanted to come because he likes going to
anime cons as well
um and i'm really close with my brother
so he came with us to ax
and we were like day drinking a bit you
know as you can see as you do it
not long after and i was like about four
or five beers deep
and that might as well be lethal
it was like 4pm okay but um and so
i i went in the back behind the
bookwalker siding thing
and i was having my signing yeah but
someone else just finished their signing
and i was with my brother and i was i
was a bit drunk you know i'm not gonna
lie
and um so meylin obviously
which you guys obviously remember from
previous episodes was there and she's
like oh do you want to meet
this guy's name who i don't even
remember and i'm just like
sure but i was pretty obviously drunk
and i shook his hand and
it's like and i started speaking my
shitty japanese i was just like
oh konichiwa hajime
and this guy's like all right and then
later did i find out that was the
author of monster music
yeah because i remember that exact same
day we were we were
we were walking around um we were
walking around the ax hall
and then we we see connor we just see
connor standing there and we don't know
why he's just standing there
and we we so before before we can we
even react
we were with some friends like it was me
sydney and some
some some of our friends yeah and cindy
just goes and like just like
says hello to connor just like just like
a good old
why is college standing just like a good
oh hey we just saw you in this
like a lot and it's like oh hey dude and
then after i said hey
i hear this like i got called like a
[ __ ] by five people
and i look to my left there's this long
line of girls ready
waiting you're [ __ ] skipping us like
i got called
[ __ ] so many times but you're fans and
i was like
holy [ __ ] i didn't know you're doing it
93 strikes
i'd call you a [ __ ] if you cut in front
of me that's a [ __ ]
no i just i just i walked away and i
said i'm sorry and then like all these
girls are just
like they were so mean if you were one
of those girls
[ __ ] you you [ __ ]
thank you for supporting me thank you
for calling sydney a [ __ ]
you made a funny story i mean i'd be
annoyed if someone cut you know what
you're just saying i didn't know i
wouldn't i was
obviously they they couldn't know the
context yeah yeah yeah because everyone
was waiting to like take a picture i
guess
i also have another story i go ahead
guys i just want to say this is actually
the coolest
one and i need to okay so we were at the
funimation party
uh at ax 2017-18
and i think it was 18. yeah it was like
two years ago i think yeah
yeah so we were drinking in it and i
obviously had to go to the bathroom and
they only had one bathroom in the place
this was the funimation party i don't
know if you mentioned it i
so i went in and then i i see this guy
just laying on the [ __ ] floor in
there
and i was like i kind of get up and i
wait so what was he in like the women's
toilet
there was only one toilet oh okay and um
he's just like face down i thought he
was dead like i thought like he
overdrank or he was like dead or
something because he was face down in
the middle of the toilet
and he wasn't moving and i kept waking
him up and then i just like i kind of
like kept shaking him and then he's just
like i realized cause he starts speaking
japanese he's a japanese guy right
yeah and then um
he's just like in the most like really
broken english he's like i'm one of the
animators for
boca no hero i'm like can you get the
[ __ ] out of the bathroom
i don't
because the guests are like some of the
animators from boca no hero were there
and he's just like there he's like i'm
like did you are you okay
like can you just get out i have to take
a piss dude and he's just like
can i see you again i'm like just get
the [ __ ] out
i'm trying to take a [ __ ] but he was
like i felt bad because he's like
obviously really wasted
hey man we all have we all yeah we've
all been there we've all been there
yeah that's more than once